Let's see. Let's talk to our caller from the
8 6 0 area code who's calling today from 8
6 0 0.
Hi, David. Can you hear me? Yes, I can. Who's
this?
This is Chris calling from Savannah, Georgia.
And my question is, last week, Trump's approval
rating kind of skyrocketed. Yeah, it's over
55 percent, I believe. Do you think that this
will really hold? I know that like during
crises, the president's approval rating kind
of goes up because people kind of rally behind
him. But since, you know, coronaviruses is
just the first thing that we have to worry
about on the recession and stuff, do you see
it necessarily holding and how will that affect
the election, do you believe?
So a couple of things. Number one, yes. Trump's
approval rating is up and his handling his
marks, as he likes to call them on coronavirus
are also pretty high. And so part of it is
that people tend to rally around the president
in a crisis, even if they're doing a pretty
bad job, as I believe Donald Trump is. I think
the other aspect of this, as you're talking
about, is that not everybody is yet feeling,
you know, when you think about 40 percent
or 35 percent of the cases are in New York,
lots. Large swaths of the country still have
very few cases that they know about.
There are probably a lot of people who are
saying, hey, things are OK here. Trump's doing
a good job. And of course, that is a lot of
people who simply aren't aware of the real
case. No, because we're not fully testing
yet. However, you bring up a good point, which
is as the unemployment numbers go up and as
this extends, if indeed it does, you may see
that level off or go the other way. But my
prediction, if you say to me, David, you've
got a bet right now, Corona virus helps or
hurts Trump in November. I bet that it helps
even if he continues to handle it poorly,
because there's plausible deniability. There's
always the idea that he could have handled
it worse and things would have been even worse
than they are. And so I if you say, David,
you've got to place a bet. Does this help
or hurt Trump in November? I believe coronavirus
helps Trump in November.
OK. Yeah. I guess that kind of makes sense.
I think that Trump's been doing.
Not not really the best job. No, trying to.
I'm back from college and my parents are like
getting mad at all those journalists and reporters
thinking that they're asking dumb questions
and stuff. And I just kind of get to put my
head down because the pile on me. But it's
just I don't know. I I kind of will begrudgingly
vote for Biden, I guess, over Trump. But I
I'm just trying to get the word out to people
because I mean, Georgia's kind of going purple.
Yep. We'll see what happens.
We will. We will. And it will really come
down to who who chooses to get out to vote
and how bad will the situation be. You know
what? What we would unfortunately, if the
Republicans are more likely to believe that
they shouldn't be staying home, we could end
up with the unfortunate situations that Republican
turnout is significantly higher than Democratic
turnout because Democrats are much more likely
to be staying at home. We don't know what
things will be like in November. You know,
it's eight months away, what, seven, seven
months away? We'll wait and see.
Yeah, that's right, sure. Well, thank you
for taking my question, David, a big fan of
the show and yes, stay safe.
Thank you. Likewise. And I appreciate you
calling in today.